[Music]
I've always been a fan of the darkside
the idea of the Imperial perspective is
you never really understand who they are
as people right how the organization
works how can we distill that and how
can we make a story around that the
story of battlefront 2 is absolutely an
essential story what happened after
Return of the Jedi what happened to the
galaxy what happened to the Empire
without an emperor what it might feel
like to be in this galaxy is it starts
to break apart what's really exciting
about this story is that we're gonna see
it from the point of view of a character
like I did so we're gonna see it from
this imperial point of view
Inferno Squad is a black ops team that
most people don't even know exist
we weren't expecting Special Forces we
happen to be on Endor when the second
death star explodes
iDEN is presented with an extreme
challenge the destruction of the Death
Star - and the death of the Emperor
what sort of choices would somebody in
that situation have to make about who
they are and what the galaxy was going
to become
and it's interesting does that mean now
that the Empire's fallen that they're
the underdogs
I even is a tried and true and through
and through Imperial she's somebody who
grew up on a planet called VAR DOS she
was very quickly put into a military
camp for children she has spent her
whole life building up to this moment to
be commander of Inferno squad well pray
this inform the Admiral that operation
syndicate proceed as planned
task is the most zealous of them all I
would say he's the most interested and
invested in how far the Empire is
willing to go he was an orphan she
needed something to latch on to Empire
his peace and justice and order even
when people are faltering around him he
pushes forward and says no the Empire is
the way I'm picking up distress calls
too many to count
del has seen more of the galaxy than
most people in the Empire he actually
grew up on Coruscant
during the time of the Jedi he brings a
lot of humor Hindman I didn't have a bit
of a banter of a bit of a laugh family
is a really important element in Star
Wars and one of the things that we
wanted to make sure we captured is the
dynamic between Garrick versio and his
daughter
iDEN versio this is the catalyst for
iDEN where she learns the future of the
Empire and she's elevated to a point by
her father here our next assignments
they are unusual she's my daughter she's
sure I have
I do need for her to understand why I'm
gonna do what I'm gonna do
everything in Star Wars is connected and
part of our job is to make sure that the
games we're making do connect back into
that larger universe but we're now able
to use this game and battlefront to as a
resource to take this information into
future development projects I think who
those gamers out there this is the
culmination of all the things that are
good in the world
video games Star Wars and a team of
people that are willing to take the time
to do the work we have to take risks we
have to be bold we have to push
everyone's boundaries and leave a good
footprint behind
[Music]
please